inevitable
and I. Am. Iron Man.
Hey.
I, uh.
Do I know you?
we're pretty close actually. Because...
I guess it worked?
yeah
it worked for me I got to live, grow up
for you I can't answer
I'm sorry it's
think I might get a bad decision
and I know it's going to be tough for you
to let go
but if someone had to do that so the
rest of us could...I'm proud of you.
and sad
I'm strong like mom
and I'm happy I'm happy we had the time
that we did and that you were there
for me until you couldn't be
if you're happy I'm happy
I love you.
I love you 3000
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my video for the Avengers
end game deleted scene of Iron Man going
into the soul world in the alternate
ending to the movie we're doing that
giant infinity saga box set giveaway for
all the films all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
your best theory for how Iron Man can
come back in Marvel phase 4 and Marvel
phase 5 so why aren't man goes into the
soul world when he snaps the nano
Infinity Gauntlet like everyone is
supposed to go into this weigh station
area as they call it during the
filmmaking process they called it the
weigh station but technically it's the
soul world instantly you sense the
mechanics of how this place works for
each different person who uses the
Infinity Gauntlet is a makeshift version
of the campsite from outside it's lake
house earlier in the movie where Ironman
found Morgan stark playing in her tent
with Pepper Potts rescue armor from the
comics the place itself is meant to be
some meaningful shared plays from each
person's history that's why / Thanos it
was this place with young Gamora on her
homeworld it's the place where he
decided to adopt her so that's why it's
so meaningful for him adult Morgan Stark
played by Kathryn Langford who you all
probably recognize tells him that
everything worked out she got to grow up
and have a happy life with Pepper Potts
everything is okay and he doesn't need
to worry about whether or not he made
the right decision in sacrificing
himself to snap the Infinity Gauntlet or
do the whole big time heist and bring
everyone back the really interesting
part too is that she also tells him that
she can't say whether or not he's alive
in the future I can't say about you
mostly because Marvel doesn't have a
contract with Robert Downey jr. to
comeback in the live-action movies
beyond the Black Widow movie there's a
rumor that he's coming back in a scene
for Black Widow but it might just wind
up being a deleted scene from Captain
America Civil War that's kind of a
separate thing I'll talk about it during
my Black Widow videos when they start
dropping trailers for that movie side
note - you probably also heard Jeff
Goldblum a recently confirmed that he
filmed scenes with Robert Downey jr. for
the Avengers what if series so he will
be coming back for new stuff during
Marvel phase 4 is just on Kevin Feige
and Marv
to find compelling reasons for him to
come back in the live-action movies like
Young Avengers or the Future Avengers
movies is a hologram or a special
message that he left behind that they
find just some compelling reason for him
to come back and play the character
aside from him just straight-up coming
back alive or an alternate universe
version the other reason why she says
this too she can't say whether or not
he's alive is because they were playing
it like he might never come back in the
future and even this version of Morgan
Stark that Ironman is talking to isn't
the actual Morgan Stark it's just a
piece of her soul that he's connected to
because of the power of the combined
Infinity stones it's kind of complicated
what's happening here the mechanics of
it all but the stones are reaching
forward in time and connecting him to a
piece of her soul pulling it into the
soul world you have to remember that
most of the movie is about them
travelling back into the past but you
can actually use the Infinity Gauntlet
to travel to any point in the future
that you want to they have a nice
callback to the I Love You 3000 line
from earlier in the movie and then after
this what would have happened is they
had the Avengers take indeed deleted
scene where they do a much bigger longer
version of the goodbye scene with
spider-man Pepper Potts and Rhodey
here's a short clip of that Iron Man 1
was incredibly special a sort of improv
the whole thing we laughed we cried we
got very very close on that movie we
were the first Marvel movie as a studio
you know there was no real model for it
yet nobody expected too much of it I
think most of us have been pretty vocal
about what he started him and without
him none of us would be in this position
the scene goes on even longer you can
even see younger Gamora from 2014 get
all awkward when they start getting down
on one knee because she never met Iron
Man she doesn't know Tony Stark so she's
like peace I'm out of here that's why
Peter Quillin thought of the guardians
of the galaxy are plotting a course to
track her ship down at the end of the
movie and that other scene but you watch
those Iron Man scenes and you probably
understand why they chose to delete them
the Iron Man's sole world scene is cool
but the whole reason why the writers
said that they originally tried to
include it was to make Iron Man feel
like things would be okay he made the
right call in the much shorter scene
with Pepper Potts saying Tony
were going to be okay in spider-man
saying goodbye right after this moment
all
so does the exact same thing in half the
time so you had about two separate
scenes doing the exact same thing the
other big reason why they cut it is
because they showed the scene to test
audiences and most of the people were
confused about who Morgan Stark was
Catherine Langford they didn't make the
connection that she was the older
version of this young little girl and
for the people that did recognize who
she was supposed to be because you've
only spent a couple of scenes with the
young Morgan Stark character most of the
people watching didn't really care that
much about her so the scene didn't wind
up carrying the weight that they wanted
it to and for most casual viewers it
just made things more confusing the
reason why they cut the Avengers taken
nice scene is because it was originally
there to just have everyone pay tribute
to Iron Man sacrifice and they also do
that again right after this during the
funeral scene so they cut it for pretty
much the same reason why they cut the
soul world scene you're doing just the
same scene over and over again making
the film longer than it needs to be and
they found that they were turning the
ending of the movie into a Lord of the
Rings Return of the King situation
remember how that movie had several
different endings like the whole last 15
to 20 minutes of Return of the King was
a bunch of different ending scenes when
really you only want one or two and then
any other tags that you want with the
different characters that you handle in
the post-credits scenes because it's a
Marvel movie but the issue they said
they had with Avengers end game is that
they wanted the movie to feel special
like a real ending for some of these
characters even though they're
definitely coming back in Black Widow
like Black Widow is gone but technically
the Black Widow movie is set during the
past so it's not quite as perfect a
situation as they would like but that's
the whole reason why they didn't want a
post-credits scene like you would see in
a traditional Marvel film and instead
did that special montage post-credit
scene with all the titles and then the
Iron Man audio taken from the cave scene
in the first Iron Man movie with him
banging the hammer making that mark 1
armor but let me know in the comments do
you think that they were right to cut
the soul world scene in the scene of
them taking a knee after Iron Man went out, there's a ton of other bonus content and
deleted scenes from the Avengers
infinity saga box set from all the
different Marvel films going back to
phase 1 let me know if there are any
special videos that you want me to make
because most of this stuff is obviously
for Avengers endgame but there's way
more stuff going back to the other films
I'm working on a new video for the
Mandalorian
Riaan about Yoda's race in their history
that should post later tonight but while
you wait for everything click here for
that brand new Avengers what if trailer
and click here for all my Avengers
endgame deleted scenes videos thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!